oh did not expect that question actually
when is the last time I cried it was
this week I had too much to drink I was
at my friend's house and he played a
certain song that always sends me until
I could almost like a a weird space I
just was really frustrated about why I'd
rather not say I cry either I'm having a
total breakdown or I'm watching a TV
show I was watching since 8:00 and I'm
Naomi and her wife and this is finale
got married and I started crying because
I thought no one would ever love me like
that I saw a beautiful boy like two
nights ago
I cried throughout the entire thing I've
got a sibling who struggled with
problems like those his whole life so I
felt like I was disappointing this
person that I was working with I am in
the process of buying a new home for my
cat drinking red wine and listening to
the Miseducation of Lauryn Hill I was
kind of seeing this guy and then I got a
text for him that he was like I don't
see anything blossomy and I was like
what but you know I responded really
chill and I was like yeah um cool thanks
for being honest and I went to my friend
mm I cried I was thinking specifically
about the idea that I moved away from
home so from here on for the rest of my
life I will only see my mom and my
family for short periods of time I was
feeling very insecure about like my life
and my job and just feeling inadequate
when my grandpa died I reconnect with my
dad this summer for the first time in
like eight nine maybe ten years they
told me that my father who had been
sober for eight years coming up on nine
years had relapsed and fallen off of a
balcony
and broke five vertebrae in his back and
a bunch of ribs that punctured his lungs
and I couldn't tell my mom and my
brother cuz they were asleep on the East
Coast and so I had to sit with that for
like six seven hours and I wasn't gonna
go to sleep I just waited for them to
wake up so I can tell them I cried on
the flight back from Tokyo because I
just couldn't imagine the fact that in
this lifetime that a black boy like me
growing up from Saint Louis Missouri
could get to experience something like
that and to just know that every
experience and opportunity we get in
life is special I was watching this
video on Facebook and this kid who is an
athlete and had a walking disability of
some sort Nike had surprised him with a
like professional athlete program I was
listening to his song I was just like oh
this song it's just so good and you know
what life it's just so fleeting it was
like dancing around enjoying the song
and then like crying because I was like
happy but then we're all gonna die you
know and just like the beauty of that I
went on YouTube and I started looking up
compilations of people finding out they
were gonna be grandparents I shared a
boat with my dad he like accomplished
something that he was doing in his own
personal life two days ago when I got
back from vacation and I saw my cat just
holding my baby puppy in my lap and I
was thinking about how much I loved her
and how grateful I am for her on my 30th
birthday it was like a barbecue and all
my friends and family came I was just
really like overwhelmed with everybody
and how much of the all like showed up
and cared I was thinking about my dad
and how proud he would be okay
[Music]
[Music]